une table ronde pour des pays en quête
d'unité un invité virtuel qui réclame à
nouveau un soutien accru pour repousser
l'envahisseur russe
le système de défense aérien moderne et
des sanctions plus sévères contre la
russie
le président hélène ce qu'ils souhaitent
que la guerre soit terminée d'ici
l'hiver les leaders du g 7 prennent acte
des demandes de l'ukraine et relèvent
leurs manches pour en arriver à une
stratégie commune
le président byden promet des canons
antiaériens le canada de nouvelles
sanctions dans le secteur des
technologies et depuis bruxelles le
secrétaire général de l'otan enchérit il
souhaite tripler le nombre de soldats de
sa force d'intervention rapide en christ
non
loin des horreurs de la guerre
forger un consensus est parfois
difficile avoue justin trudeau
le chancelier allemand prévient qu'il
faut éviter une escalade entre l'otan et
la russie les dirigeants au château elle
marc se retrouve donc devant une horizon
incertain
de g7 lance donc une opération charme
cinq pays en voie de développement ont
été invités en bavière des pays qui
hésitent à dénoncer publiquement la
russie en les aidant à surmonter la
crise alimentaire causée par la guerre
le g7 espèrent les inciter à tourner le
dos à la russie dans une stratégie qui
vise à isoler vladimir poutine mais si
une volonté d'aider dans ce contexte là
aussi encore plus fort les pays
émergents c'est des moments importants
pour délit de progresser justement de
continuer à voir avoir un impact positif
dans un monde qui est de plus en plus
trouble prochaine étape demain au sommet
de l'otan les premier ministre du japon
de l'australie et de la corée du sud
seront évités pour la première fois
devant à l'agressivité de la russie et
la montée en force de la chine les pays
membres de l'otan se cherche de nouveaux
alliés ici christian noël radio-canada à
garmisch partenkirchen en allemagne